the metropolitan police have announced
that their investigation into alleged
coveted breaches at whitehall and in
downing street during the lockdowns has
concluded the met has said that in total
detectives have made 126 referrals for
fixed penalty notices to the acro
criminal records office for breaches of
covid 19 regulations the referrals refer
to events on eight separate dates the
20th of may 2020 the 18th and 19th of
june 2020 the 13th of november 2020 the
17th and 18th of december 2020 the 14th
of january last year and the 16th of
april last year the met says that of the
referrals all will result in a fixed
penalty notice being issued it says the
breakdown of recipients is that uh they
are 53 men and 73 women and some people
have received more than one fixed
penalty notice the met says that it will
not be referring or conf releasing or
confirming the identity of anyone
released in the investigation or
providing any further details of its
findings in line with the approach that
it has taken from the pandemic and the
met goes on to say our position from
early on in the pandemic was that we
would not routinely investigate historic
breaches of covid regulations this was
for two reasons first that we could not
retrospectively engage and inform those
involved that they were breaching the
rules an important step in our policing
strategy around covid and that secondly
as these were summary only offenses we
did not judge it a proportionate use of
officers time and the met goes on to say
we did recognize there might be some
exceptions in this approach and we set
out at the time the criteria that would
be need for us to be met to consider a
retrospective investigation and the met
goes on to say uh those included that
there was evidence that those involved
uh should have known that they were
breaching the regulations of what they
knew was doing was an offense when not
investigating would significantly
undermine the legitimacy of the law and
where there was little ambiguity around
the absence of any reasonable defense so
the met investigation has tied up we can
speak now to our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen for her reaction there
tomorrow what do you make of this
morning ian well big news from
westminster about that partygate
investigation which has really dominated
the past few months and at times looked
as if it was putting boris johnson's
premiership in jeopardy it's concluded
there have been 126
penalty notices issued as far as we know
the prime minister has only got that one
from the beginning we do not know that
he's had any more since then and downing
street did tell us that we would be told
if he had
of those 126 they cover eight different
events one being that birthday party
that um
that that the prime minister had with it
with the sing-along interestingly
none of the dates uh include so that the
20th of may which was the event
including the email invite to his
socially distanced drinks is included on
that list but we
don't believe thus far the prime
minister has received a penalty notice
over that just taking in this very long
statement they tell us
how many officers worked on it they
worked through hundreds 345 documents
and over 500 photographs and they
explained in detail as you were setting
out there why they decided to
investigate this breach retrospectively
having not done so before because they
they did so in cases where they feel it
would significantly undermine the
legitimacy of the law not to have done
so so partygates concluded
if the prime minister only gets one fine
that will put him in a significantly
better position regarding his mps than
it would do if he received more than
that but what will now happen is that we
will get the sue grey report into all
the details of what happened at those
events and we'll be waiting for updates
from the cabinet office about when that
will happen